-Guys, as I mentioned earlier,
the C.E.O.s of the biggest tech
companies in the country spoke
before Congress today
to defend
their business practices.
In case you missed it,
we put together a highlight reel
of Facebook's Mark Zuckerberg
getting questioned.
Check it out.
-Please state your name
and title to the committee.
-I'm Mark Zuckerberg,
C.E.O. of Facebook,
a perfect website that has never
done anything wrong.
-Mr. Zuckerberg, how do you
respond to people who say
your company has grown into
a monopoly?
-I don't see Facebook
as a monopoly.
We want other social-media
platforms to succeed.
We just want their success to be
under the Facebook banner
and all the money they make
go to Facebook.
-What are you doing to counter
fake news?
-Okay, obviously our company
needs to take
a more proactive role
with false information.
That's why I'm excited to unveil
a new emoji people can use
when they think something
is not real.
We know these guys --
like, love --
the faces humans make
when they feel emotions.
But now we have
the "hmm" reaction.
If you see an article
that says DNA tests confirms
Obama is a descendant
of Dracula,
you can click the hmm face,
and that will
let your friends know
"Hey, here is one person
who thinks this story
might not be up to snuff."
-Uh, Mr. Zuckerberg,
I think you froze.
-No.
This is just how my face is.
-What do you have to say about
the Facebook advertiser boycott?
You lost a lot of huge sponsors
like Starbucks.
-Forget Starbucks.
I want to welcome
a more prestigious
caffeinated beverage company
to the Facebook family --
Gush Force X100
Energy Discharge.
Gush Force has
500% more caffeine
than the FDA recommends.
It's been banned
in nine countries.
Facebook will be running
Gush Force ads
until it's banned in
our country,
and if they want to keep
paying us still after that.
Facebook is a public good.
It's the only place
where you can interact with
elderly conspiracy theorists
who think the moon
is a big lizard egg
as well as bots from Senegal
who try to sell you fraudulent
Buffalo Bills tickets.
You should be more concerned
about TikTok.
They're owned by China.
TikTok collects personal info
without consent,
has been used to spread
fake news,
and is a national security
threat.
If anyone is going to do
that stuff,
it should be an American
company, like Facebook.
I'm going take all your concerns
to heart.
Now, who should I write
the check out to?
-Mr. Zuckerberg, can you please
blink for us?
You haven't blinked at all
this entire hearing,
and it's very upsetting.
-Sure.